the title of today's event is what's
left for the left rebuilding progressive
politics it's got a kind of hopeful and
less hopeful side to it I guess it's
brought to you by the Pointer fellowship
which is a fellowship here at Yale that
brings distinguished journalist to the
campus and we certainly have two
distinguished journalist here today one
more recent entry into the field than
the other I'm Jacob hacker I'm a
professor of political science here and
before we begin I'd just like to to
announce a lost item that I hope that
you can help us find liberalism's mojo
so hopefully we can start to find it
today there I said it liberalism I did
not vaporize as Governor Christie would
put it yes it was it was once an
acceptable word in Europe it's still
proudly used however it's used by the
folks that we would call conservatives
here in the United States that is
classical liberals who endorse who argue
for free markets limited limited
government American liberals have been
struggling to try to rebrand themselves
for quite a while now the latest label
the one we use today is progressivism
which sort of harkens back to the early
20th century struggle to create a decent
industrial society and that's the the
term of art that we will use today now
it's no secret that progressivism is
facing shall we say a bit of a
challenging situation it's no better
summed up I think than by a bumper
sticker that a friend of mine saw the
other day it read GOP OMG WTF yes it was
on a it was on a Prius and and in a
sense from a liberal perspective we
faced two major crashes in the last few
years the first is the one we all know
about the one that seemed almost
tailor-made to describe it the governing
economic philosophy of the prior
generation the one that really drove
home the gap between Wall Street and
Main Street and the second crash is the
one of the hopes that were invested in
that moment in the 2007
2008 downturn and campaign and in of
course President Barack Obama you know
at the time we talked about we liberals
talked about yes we can there was even
talk of a new new deal but a funny thing
happened on the way to the new new deal
it ran into some very serious hurdles
and then of course in November 2010
there was a major electoral reversal and
a total shift in the political agenda
away from measures to create jobs or
provide some modicum of Economic
Security to spending cuts the expansion
of or creation of favorable tax
provisions for the affluent and
corporations and a very serious
state-by-state push for deregulation
programmatic cutbacks and anti union
rules so today we're going to talk about
what explains these developments more
important we're going to talk about what
they say about the future of
progressivism in the United States we'll
ask what extent they reflect the poor
strategies of Democrats or the savvy
tactics of their opponents alternatively
we'll talk about to what extent they
reflect structural difficulties in
American politics for example the
imbalance of order of organizational
might between ordinary Americans and the
affluent and corporations or the
difficulty of achieving super majority
support for new policy initiatives in an
increasingly polarized Washington where
the filibuster reigns supreme we'll ask
what role the media plays in this story
we'll ask whether progressivism has to
recast itself for a new era we'll ask if
it can win over middle-class voters and
what its key goals should be going
forward so those are some pretty big
questions fortunately we have a very
able group of panelists the first is
Howard Dean he was governor of Vermont
for 12 years you may also know that he
ran for president in 2003 after his run
he became chairman of the Democratic
National Committee we political
scientists are always cautious about
confusing correlation and causation but
I'll note that when he was chair of the
DNC the Democrats gained it historically
in two thousand six and two thousand
eight and he managed to leave afterwards
before the 2010 debacle
he now serves as a CNBC contributor and
all and all his spare time he's
apparently doing a lot of grassroots
organizing Katrina vanden Heuvel is the
editor and publisher of the Nation
magazine she writes a weekly column at
the nation editor's cut she has a weekly
web column at the Washington Post in her
spare time she speaks around the country
including at our fair university and and
as she charmingly puts it she does some
TV and then finally Daniel Horning is a
yale college junior and president of the
Yale chapter of the progressive
undergraduate organization the Roosevelt
Institute in his role as president of
Roosevelt he oversees the progressive
think tank six domestic and
international policy centers he has no
free time so let me just say a few words
about our agenda where i'll be going
until around five thirty after some
brief opening statements from each of
our panelists will talk for about a half
an hour among ourselves i'll be
moderating about some of the challenges
and opportunities of progressivism today
then i'm going to open it up about 45
minutes into our program i'll be opening
it up to discussion among all of us
there are microphones in the audience
you can see there are two here please
step up to them when you ask questions
and I have just three requests to make
before before we move to the statements
of our panelists the first is since this
is a very contested subject I hope we
can speak about it in a civil way
putting that aside i will also just ask
at a minimum second that you when you
come up you actually ask a question it's
always useful and then finally if you
have a cell phone and i guess who
doesn't these days and you brought it
with you if you could silence it for the
remainder of our forum i'd really
appreciate it so with no further ado let
me turn the program over to Governor
Dean thanks very much
Thank You Jacob I'm going to try to stay
within my seven minutes and if I don't
there's somebody over here is going to
wave her hand wildly if I go over it
right I think there is a difference
between the three terms the left liberal
and progressive and I'll tell you what
it is in my own mind the left you'd have
to be around in the 60s to remember what
the left was like or perhaps in the 40s
in the 30s was a well-organized group of
people who were actually mirror images
to the right that his ideology mattered
a lot there was a certain amount of
propaganda involve facts didn't always
matter I can remember the debates when I
was here as an undergraduate on the left
about a class structure and if you
didn't agree and you didn't measure up
to the doctrine than you were considered
impure and not sufficiently perfect so
you know the left there used to be a
left in America and it used to look a
lot like the intolerance of the right
and they even did outrageous things
although they weren't quite as good at
subverting democracy is the right so
that's the left we haven't seen any of
that around here there's a few little
vestigial parts of it but I don't know
any young person who would be really
classified as left liberals i classify
as people who are well-intentioned
managed well smart well-educated not
particularly doctrinaire but can't quite
keep their manage the money that is the
older group many of my cohorts and I in
head up falling out with liberals that
lasted a long time on money issues when
I was governor can't quite figure out
how to limit their spending to what they
can take in it's not so much about tax
policy because tax policy really is an
argument on a continuum how much do you
tax how much do you spend and of course
a liberal group is going to want to tax
more and spend more on social things
supposedly but in fact the right really
just borrows and spends instead which of
course has led us to where we are today
interesting factoid from the CBO which
is the last non-partisan budget
Authority in Congress the bush tax cuts
are responsible for sixty percent of the
deficit in 2019 when you run the deficit
out it's not the Iraq war in the Africa
we're which haven't been paid for it's
not Medicare it's the bush tax cuts
sixty percent of the deficit you don't
hear a lot about that their truth is
that Republicans are as profligate as
the Liberals were in terms of actually
money that's just the Liberals used to
tax and balance the budget and the
Republicans cut taxes and then gave away
money to the oil companies of course in
the traditional both parties and but but
didn't pay for that by cutting the
budget and which leads me to what the
definition of a progressive is I think
it actually a progressive it properly
understood is it might embrace what the
new generation this young under 35
generation that elected Barack Obama
might be a dose of libertarianism a
pretty conservative approach to money
but a very strong commitment very much
actually like what I consider be Vermont
a combination of libertarianism
communitarianism pregnant pragmatism and
a desire to work together I think one of
the reasons that Barack Obama was
elected president with this enormous
outpouring of under 35s this is the
first election in my lifetime were more
people under 35 voted than who voted who
were over 65 I've never seen that before
this new generation who elected their
first president really elected somebody
who represented them much as my first
president was John F Kennedy even though
he was older than my father he really
represented a new approach a new
boldness and new way of looking at
things well their president is barack
obama and i think part of the problem
the president's gotten himself into he
really does in the spirit of the people
who elected him which is the under 35s
want to work together with people you
want to set aside whatever ideological
differences and build a country and
solve problems i think that's that i
don't think most of the young people who
went out and voted for Barack Obama are
Democrats there are Democrats now they
need not be in the future that we can
probably talk about some of the things
the conservators you can have to do in
order to get them but they are people
who really want solutions to thing and
those things and those are the kinds of
things that Barack Obama spoke about
when he was campaigning unfortunately he
then had to go to Washington which is
that where the last place that anybody
really understands what's going on in
the country other than the floor of the
United States and the Washington Post
which are the very last places it
underst
what's going on in the rest of the
country and then he so he has the deal
with what's left over from the culture
wars in my generation I'm a culture
warrior and I'll never be anything but
it's in my DNA I can't stand it when
certain issues are you know push my
buttons and I want to go to war that's
not what the younger generation wants to
do and it's not what the how the
president is programmed either for lots
of different reasons I think time is on
our hands on our side I think that the
Tea Party is a transitory movement
Newsweek have is a great article I
haven't read yet but it's a great cover
I talking about 50 year old males on the
beached male i think it's entitled and
it's true if you look at the tea party
that they are overwhelmingly white over
55 and christian that is not the
demographics of the united states of
america and it's certainly not the
democrats the demographics of the rising
generation this is a transitory motion
it's very powerful and the smaller it
gets the more powerful and we're all
organizing angrier they're going to get
but ultimately demography is going to
wash them away as it has in california
image you know as you well know the
demographics in this country have been
changing tremendously soon a California
hasn't had a majority for a long time
they have five pretty substantial
minorities and then a whole lot of other
ones as most cosmopolitan places do so
every morning folks who have grown up
thinking America was a certain way and
they the people that ran America looked
like them are reminded on morning
television that in fact somebody else's
in charge that doesn't exactly look like
them although most younger people think
that the President does look like them
and he does he's the first multi general
generational a multicultural president
put in by the first multicultural
generation in American history so I
think the time is on our side I think
we're going to end up not being more
fiscally conservative as a result of
progressivism and I think we're going to
be extremely libertarian and much more
tolerant of other people this is not by
the way a tolerant generation this is an
inclusive generation and it's going to
have an enormous effect I suspect that
2010 was the first half of the tea party
2012 will be the last is off of the Tea
Party
and now Katrina vanden Heuvel yeah maybe
this needs to be ear piece in my ear
that the right didn't and you actually
don't need this microphone this the long
struggle Patrol you know between reform
and reaction in this country has been
part of her history but I think this is
a moment and I you know I don't want to
quibble with the good governor about
categories left progressive liberal I do
think there is a left and it's a left
that is about a politics but all liberal
progressive left about a politics of
decency of dignity of real security that
does have to grapple with what governor
Dean spoke of in terms of the
libertarian strain in our country's
history and tradition and I think there
is a strong strand of community and
localism that is there to be built on to
expand our coalition's and our
communities because I think we need to
develop coalition's with people who
might not be our natural allies in trans
partisan ways to pick up on Jacobs work
I mean I think the society today as
governor Dean said is more socially
tolerant inclusive the demographics are
on our side but there's no question that
the broad movement of us politics
economy in the last decade decades 30 40
years has been toward greater inequality
the discrediting of public institutions
and corporate power unprecedented we are
witnessing the rise of corporate power
and there too by the way I think in the
sense of community and localism
countering corporate power if one might
say small see capitalism versus big see
corporate power you have the possibility
of this transport as an alliance after
the Citizens United decision don't
forget that poll showed vast majorities
across the political spectrum were
fearful of this overweening corporate
power you know we are now at a moment as
William gryder wrote a few years ago in
the nation and Harold Meyerson a
terrific columnist for The Washington
Post wrote just a few weeks ago where we
are witnessing forces trying to repeal
the 20th century they are trying to roll
back the civilizing advances and reforms
of certainly post New Deal 20th century
it is in that long assiduous struggle
that we have seen the rise patient rise
well-funded rise of a conservative right
and at this moment it seems to me that
one of the key tasks for progressives is
to engage inside and outside what do I
mean to engage in independent social
movements at scale not only to defeat
some of the worst proposals coming out
of Congress and state legislatures to
weaken unions to basically reimpose a
new defunded social contract but i think
it is also too you know shred a safety
net for the most vulnerable but we must
also begin to challenge the limits of
the debate I thought President Obama's
speech the other day laid out a very
eloquent vision of progressive
governance but the logic in the details
wasn't fully there in terms of
challenging the limits of the debate on
our economic front we need to challenge
and lay out a new affirmative economic
agenda you know the debate in Washington
and in establishment circles in this
country has always been out of touch
with the realities of people's lives but
I think the gap today has perhaps never
been wider some of that is reflected in
Jacob hackers work the rise of what is
it seven to eight lobbyists for each
elected representatives the rise of
money that corruption the corroded war
political system there are good people
inside Washington though I was just
meeting with a great student group on
this campus snap students for new
American politics which is linked up
with some
the new forces in progressive American
political life the Progressive Caucus 83
strong laid out of budget last week
called the people's budget did it get
any attention except for a snarky column
excuse me by my colleague dana Milbank
in the Washington Post who thought
people's was too reminiscent of the
People's Republic of Berkeley the
people's budget laid out how to protect
a strong social safety net progressive
taxation and how do we end to Wars that
are looting our treasury and not making
us more secure it is in this movement
building fused with rebuilding a
progressive electoral strategy that I
think we see some real possibility and
it is also in laying down a new set of
debates in challenging a kind of
establishment consensus I wanted to read
something which I find I carry around
with me if you can believe it by our
editorial board member Tony Kushner what
used to be called liberal is now called
radical what used to be called radical
is now called insane what used to be
called reactionary is now called
moderate and what used to be called
insane is now called solid conservative
thinking I mean this is a measure of
where the debate has moved and those of
you who have traveled in parts of this
world understand that in this country we
have a strange situation where it's the
debate is being played out on a
center-right terrain I do think the
progressive liberal community needs to
speak in a language that is more
connected to peoples lived experiences I
think in some of what governor dean said
in the sense of speaking to communities
also in reclaiming the idea of freedom
which corey robin a very smart young
thinker wrote about in the pages of the
nation last week where you put freedom
on the side of government not as on the
side necessarily of markets which are
constraining of freedom these are first
principle ideas that need to be engaged
because we are in a struggle of ideas we
are in a struggle to expand the debate
in our country we are in a struggle now
to reclaim the twentieth and move into
the 21st century in smart bold ways and
i think
it's going to demand a younger
generation and Here I am because I think
governor Dean is right if you look at
the Tea Party and hell I'm proud of my
husband he has a great Medicare card
social security card and may I say that
Social Security is a contract between
workers and their government it is not
an entitlement and it should not be used
in the same sentence as deficit but I do
think the future lies with young people
with the changing demographics of this
country not with a tea party which is
confused by the way seventy percent the
other day said don't touch my Medicare
reprising the summer of 2008 and we have
made some progress I could talk more
about a group that was seeded out of the
nation called us uncut but i do think on
Tax Day 2011 the narrative was a little
less about the Tea Party and a little
more about how we need a fair share
politics demanding the corporations pay
their taxes and that the very richest in
this country pay their fair share and in
that shift is the possibility of a new
politics that we need to keep driving
into the debate into Washington
interstates and into communities around
this country thank
last but not least Daniel mornin I just
want to begin by thanking your professor
hacker and thanking the pointer
fellowship for inviting me to
participate today it's a real honor to
be here among such leaders in the
progressive movement when we start by
defining progressivism I think it's
valuable to go back to John Dewey who in
many respects was one of the founders of
American progressivism itself and he of
course said that arriving at one goal is
the starting point to another I think
this reveals some things for us about
what progressivism might not be it's not
a set of agreed-upon policies so though
necessary and good social security for
example isn't inherently progressive
Medicare isn't inherently progressive I
think sometimes we have a tendency as
liberals to get caught up in New Deal
policies or in politics of the civil
rights movement and that's a mistake
that is harmful to progressives I think
if we focus as progressives on
consistently striving to move forward
this idea that government can be a tool
to increase opportunity across the board
in this country I think that's the
narrative that is most helpful for
progressives so because I'm the youngest
person on the panel though governor Dean
certainly does compete with me when it
comes to being young its spirit and I
get lifted I've been asked to focus a
little bit on the challenges and the
possibilities of progressivism
specifically when it comes to young
people and a younger generation so I'd
like to talk about two ideas one more
political in nature and one more policy
oriented that I think illustrates some
of the wider themes and that theme kind
of being that though our values and our
ideology is good and important and worth
fighting for there's some important
changes that we can make to the policies
and the politics we use to get there the
first example the policy oriented one
has more to do with the response in 2008
to the financial crisis that we saw on
the left there were the economists
further to the left like Roemer and
Krugman who insisted that we
stimulus you know above a trillion
dollars and then there were those
political advisors in the White House
like Axelrod and Emmanuel who said that
it needed to be smaller you know half a
trillion dollars or seven hundred
billion dollars so this was a debate the
crux of which was big stimulus versus
less big stimulus this was in many ways
a 1930s debate to a problem that
occurred in 2008 very few in the
policy-making circles on the left in the
White House and in Congress said hold on
a second you know are the money
multiplier might be smaller than it was
in the 1930s in the 1940s we spend less
money at home more money abroad than we
did then we have more personal debt to
pay off than we did then so maybe a
simple stimulus might not have been as
effective maybe we should be working to
put money in the pockets of small
businesses and medium-sized businesses
that are actually creating jobs in this
country and because of this we saw what
we now know was largely a jobless
recovery so I think it's going to be the
role of our generation to move the left
forward on policies past a kind of New
Deal era policies to policies that are
consistent with our vision but that are
appropriate for the 21st century and the
political issue that I want to focus on
and they're really so many issues about
the changing landscape that we could
talk about but I think one that's
particularly interesting is this idea
that on the in a young and our younger
generation we are emerging Lee more
progressive or libertarian on social
issues as governor Dean said people our
age are more likely to be in favor of
gay marriage they're more likely to be
in favor of abortion rights in favor of
legalization of marijuana just to name a
few but something that's a surprise to
many is that our generation also tends
to be more religious than our parents
generation was we are more likely to
attend worship weekly we're more likely
to believe in God and I think that
presents a really interesting
opportunity for the left to really shift
what has been a dialogue that is both
divisive and difficult for progressives
to navigate to one that really unites
the values that
widgeon teach many of us the values of
compassion the values of acceptance the
values of tolerance and inclusion with
those emerging social issues that are
more and more popular today I think that
would be both productive for
progressives politically but also would
be productive in moving forward a
discourse that many are disappointed
with on a daily basis so those are just
two examples one political and one
policy oriented that I think begin to
illustrate some of the opportunities
facing progressives when it comes to
young people today and I look forward to
discussing more of them later on Thank
You Daniel
okay well so we've moved to the second
part of our conversation in which I will
be moderating a discussion among our
panelists and then we'll be turning
opening that up to the audience as a
hole in it and I think that Daniels come
Daniels presentation really gets us off
on the right foot of asking moving a
little bit beyond the inside the beltway
concerns about current fights and
thinking a little bit about what
progressivism stands for and and whether
and how it would update it needs to
update itself for a new century so I'd
be interested in getting Daniel just
spoke of interesting getting governor
Dean and Katrina's vanden Heuvel
reactions to Daniel's ideas and at this
point I think we'll just have a
conversation while seated in fact I'll
join you guys down here so I'm not
looming over the discussion so given the
challenges of the budget deficit the
increasingly global nature of our
economy some of the demographic shifts
as you talked about what are the
important themes that progressives need
to claim or reclaim and and what are
some of the ways in which what we
typically understand is progressive
politics need to update itself well let
me just say that I had a small paying of
fear when you talked about rejecting
that or not he didn't say rejecting but
being careful not to get caught in the
New Deal mentality because for example a
sophisticated young person some of them
and I know think that privatizing so
Medicare might were Social Security
might be okay because you after all you
build this account up and so forth and
so on well I think without the
understanding of the history of the
program for example Social Security
really was a safety net for old people
it was never intended to be a retirement
income so while having 401 k's is great
we should encourage that and so forth
there needs to be a basic social safety
net that's paid for the way Social
Security is paid for and the reason for
that is that ultimately if you go down
the 401 K root and dismantle Social
Security which is what the Republicans
would like to do eventually you get
confronted when people turn get to get
older about what happens when people
either through bad luck or bad planning
can't feed themselves and then you're
back in the nineteen twenty six in the
farms
it's where social security started where
somebody has to do something about it so
I think it's really important one of my
most favorite sayings is George
Santayana those who do not learn from
history are doomed to repeat it I think
as you're evolving you're more
libertarian program which I mostly
approve of you've got to be sure you
look back at the history of the programs
in the New Deal and then your zeal to
get beyond the New Deal you don't want
to turn all of it turn your back on all
of it because some of it was put in for
a very good reason it ought not to be
forgotten I second the emotion no I
think it's critical to build on our
history I I it is it is an interesting
question that out of the crisis of the
depression came keynesianism or preceded
but it was then part of a governing
policy and politics and then you had in
the 70s neoliberalism which I think has
been discredited and what comes next is
it a kind of fusion keynesianism for the
21st century is it something a fusion
economic policy which we haven't seen
but you know I'm reminded what you know
the governor said about Medicare we're
also talking about the Great Society
which is another period which in many
ways has been discredited in the public
mind by not only some of its failings of
course but I think again a concerted
conservative program over the last 40
years but it is important it seems to me
to take for example the financial crisis
we have just lived through some of the
factors for that or because of this new
globalized economy but first and
foremost you know one of the reasons
goes back to a Clinton era policy in the
repeal of glass-steagall which was a
very important New Deal policy and one
of the reasons I think that you haven't
seen you're beginning to see real
protests in the States as people are
directly assaulted their lives challenge
their livings but you know the buffers
of the New Deal maintained a level of
security that was not the case back then
whether it was you know the so whether
it's social security medicare FDIC
II and that is something to consider
finally I mean we are you know it is a
globalized world we're not going to roll
that back but it is globalization the
question should be globalization by home
for whom and under whose control and I
think that is a central debate for our
times and one that hasn't been
sufficiently engaged and too often again
partly because of the money in our
system there are trade policies that
benefit corporations more than working
people and I think that's something to
factor in and President Obama though I
believe one man one election cannot
change a system that has so many moving
parts and so much need of reform that
will come about again the history the
New Deal was the social movements the
social movements which were stronger but
made President Roosevelt do things move
him beyond his own limits of his own
politics but President Obama I believe
had a chance in that crisis not simply
to resuscitate the financial sector we
have and we live in this hyper
financialized world but to restructure
the financial sector so that it would be
a different balance of power that we the
people would be masters not the Masters
of the Universe our masters and I think
that is worth reflecting on in terms of
a new progressivism and it speaks to the
localism the community the small C
taming capitalism which I find
fascinating and moving across this
country so there's there's an agenda
here that is sort of reclaiming some of
the core values of the progressive
project particularly the need to create
checks and balances of corporate power
to sync think seriously about an address
inequality both social and political but
obviously the in the current context of
the two responses that are most often
thrown at those who offer such sunny
future visions is one that we as a
nation cannot afford to maintain the
kind of social contract that we've
established over the last 60 years
and a second argument that often lurks
behind that one especially when one
tries to point out that the budgetary
possibilities is well even if we would
want to that that what progressives are
selling isn't the public is not buying
and so I wonder if we could speak to
both of those subjects so close to the
current debate today first of all what
you mentioned governor Dean the need for
a more fiscally conservative of
progressivism or rather that liberal
fiscal progressivism was a fiscal
conservative version of liberalism to
some some extent and so I'd like you to
elaborate on that a little bit and then
I wonder if Daniel you could you could
come in and say a little bit about how
you see the current debates about the
future of the social contract
particularly given the centrality of
programs for the Aged Medicare and
Social Security in those debates and
whether young Americans feel as if
there's a place in that in that contract
for them and what would be the place the
progressives could offer it if if the
central ideal is as Katrina said that
the government's on the side of ordinary
Americans so I would just say fiscal
conservatism has nothing to do with
conservatives are there are no
conservatives who I know that are
seriously fiscally conservative except
perhaps people like Ron Paul who has
other deficits but people who say
they're conservatives aren't
conservative at all they don't they
don't hate deficits they ferment
deficits they cause deficits that cause
deficits by outrageous corporate
giveaways which is the oil companies and
others they have huge tax cuts mostly
done not benefiting ordinary Americans
and actually most people in this country
believe the Republicans don't care about
them which is why their ratings are just
actually slightly worse than the
Democrats in Congress so when I say
fiscal conservatism I mean real
conservatism I mean you cannot spend
what you don't have and that you can't
slavishly balance the federal budget
because it will be times in downturns
where you can the only people who can
run a deficit but that you really do
have to taper your ability to spend for
good things
to your ability to raise money and keep
the economy going so the difference
between between what I would say is a
fiscal conservative progressive and
people that people that call themselves
conservatives today is that we're really
seeking to find a fair society a society
with justice that is if you want
capitalism succeed everybody has to
benefit from it not just those at the
top and I say this as a capitalist I
consider myself to be a capitalist but
capitalism is like every other system
invented by man if it doesn't have
limits then it destroys itself which I
mean the biggest danger to capitalism
today is American capitalists it's true
because the fact that that the the
average CEO now makes almost more than I
think 500 times what their workers may
do a tenfold increase over what was
going on in the 50s is a danger to
capitalism that leads to social
instability this is not someone on the
Left talking this is a sociological
observation that goes back centuries all
the way to the Pharaohs so we what we
have to guard I happen to think
capitalism is a terrific system because
the the Shumba tyrion process of
creative destruction is one that is very
effective and efficient but it has to be
regulated within some means so that it
becomes a fair system if Henry Ford has
a nerd head and when he was living at a
nice house in Grosse Pointe on the lake
his people who worked in that his
factory didn't necessarily aspire to
Henry Ford's house but they would have
liked to have be able to rent a cottage
on lake michigan once in a while and
they did in the 50s his unions were
strong so the purpose of unions is not
because we like unions for ideological
reasons the person purpose is that it's
a mechanism to make sure that capitalism
benefits everybody both those who
control the capital and those who create
the capital by their labors and I think
we've got to keep that in mind as
progressive this is a balancing act what
I think progressives are not is
ideological people on the Left who
simply have the opposite point of view
of those who are on the right where what
we can do is is look at issues that we
care about in a thoughtful balanced way
without an ideological litmus test and
try to figure out how to make this
society work for all of us which is
exactly the progress that was made by
human kind of the 20th century which the
right-wingers are trying to roll back so
I'd like to just start with this idea
that we can't afford to maintain the
social contract I think a more relevant
point is that we literally can't afford
not to maintain a social contract and
this is not some it's we don't say this
enough progressives who are in
leadership right now are people who we
think of as progressives and leadership
right now don't point this out enough
and then I also won't talk about the go
back a little bit to the to the New Deal
point because when I was talking about
moving beyond some New Deal policies I
think it's important that every time we
have that discussion it'd be about
moving past the policies but maintaining
the values of the New Deal and
maintaining the protections and the
structures that we have privatization of
Social Security just doesn't do that and
that's why we can't afford it there may
be something in the future that comes up
that lets us modernize Social Security
or modernize one of these important
programs that we can afford to do and
that we should do and we should be open
to those privatization isn't the answer
and that's not one of them and then
finally on this deficit and spending
point people tend to think in this
moment for some reason that
conservatives or fiscal conservatives
where those who poses fiscal
conservatives are in the right and have
the political momentum on their side I
think it's a lot more complicated than
that because you look at voters young
and old yes they do say they want
something serious done about the deficit
and the reality is all of us want
something serious done but if you look
at any of these programs and the Tea
Party does this but I think this is
across the spectrum elderly voters they
want their social security kept younger
voters we don't want funding for public
universities to go away so we want the
deficit cut in theory but we want our
programs to stay and I think this is
something that progressives need to take
advantage of in being real list
dick but being compassionate and serious
about our approach to the deficit and I
think President Obama started to do that
in the speech the other day it'll be
interesting to see whether the approach
changes a little bit as we go through
the legislative process but I think
we're starting to see this and it's
something that will be good for
progresses politically and is something
that'll be good for the country in
general well that's a good starting
point for my for the second half of that
question I asked before which is really
about where Americans are many of these
issues and you know I think back to a
study that was done by political
scientists just after World War Two
where they defined Americans as
philosophical conservatives and
operational liberals that is they hated
government in the abstract and they
loved everything that government did in
practice which is a pretty pretty good
definition a pretty good summing up of
the point that Daniel was just make
making there's been a stream of books
from what's the matter with Kansas to
its offshoots that have argued have
tried to sort of grapple with the
question of why are republicans winning
elections even though Americans seem to
be siding with with progressive the
progressive side of the debate in many
in many contemporary struggles I mean
Katrina mentioned the agenda disconnect
today and it really is striking on a
whole host of issues so I'm curious
what's your own diagnosis is it what not
what's the matter with Kansas but why
are middle-class Americans seemingly
less receptive to these arguments than
we might think they would be given the
fact that we have levels of inequality
of the United States not seen since just
before the Great Depression or given
that we just had a massive financial
crisis brought on by the reckless
behavior of Wall Street actors and I'll
let you lead it off since you brought up
the agenda disconnected I mean let me
ground it in what I think and this is
maybe too grounded and not sort of first
principle but I think there was a moment
where the stimulus however large however
small was framed and managed in such a
way that it became conflated with the
bank bank bailouts and in the minds of
millions of Americans left right it was
this bank bailout that
find the Obama administration's first
foray into trying to bring recovery to
this country and that then of course
generated tragically in my view a kind
of right-wing populist movement instead
of what could be more of a progressive
populist movement and that is where we
were and I think we're shifting out of
it in interesting ways it's not fully
clear yet but you know I don't trust all
polls there more snapshots but if more
and more these polls show this
disconnect between vast majority of
people who would rather see cuts in the
defense budget or who would rather see
taxes increased certainly corporations
paying something and on the very rich
and i think in there but of course
there's sort of three tracks that define
so much of this taxes are very difficult
a difficult issue in this country i
think when we needs to do a lot to
reconnect the purpose of taxes to the
essential services people are receiving
that that there has been this disconnect
in that area regulation i think much of
the rights campaign has been to roll
back regulations i saw you know the
story on rolling back environmental
regulations all kinds i'm elizabeth
warren has been a very eloquent powerful
common-sense speaker about the role of
government and regulation in peoples
lived experiences and lives and that is
critical to ground it in food safety in
clean air in credit card debt in not
allowing these for-profit colleges to
rip off people so and that then finally
relates to the role of government in
this libertarian streak there are people
who say don't tread on me but there is a
role for government that maybe not on
your back but on your side i come back
to that and it becomes more difficult
because we sit here it's the BP first
year anniversary and we see in some of
these agencies which were designed to
regulate and check the power of
corporations that those very agencies
have been captured by the agencies they
are designed to rage
and that is where but I think there's
the possibility of fairness of moving
forward to explain to people that there
are different kinds of capitalism I kind
of disagree with the governor because I
think we're living in a moment I agree
and disagree we're living in a moment of
crony capitalism not a small sea
people's capitalism we're living at a
moment of a democracy deficit which is
far more critical in my view than the
actual deficit hysteria and I would
disagree I mean I think we are a very
rich country and this mantra we cannot
afford we cannot afford has so coloured
our debates that the imagination needed
to see a different way forward an
alternative is going to take a lot of
work on the part of progressives ideas
what you're engaged with and in
movements I think there's an opportunity
to cleave off small businesses the
Chamber of Commerce no longer represents
small businesses in this country and I
think there are alternative enlightened
business people that could be allies in
enlarging a constituency that needs to
be enlarged first of all let me
recommend a book to you but I drew what
drew westen is a neuropsychologist at
Emory called the political brain and I
think this is a central problem for us
and why it's why Democrats can't message
truth is everybody votes their emotions
we just don't admit it on our side drew
says you should never go to a focus
group because they always lie now they
don't lie because they set out to lie
they lie because they believe that they
have a cognitive explanation for why
they vote and it's emotional so the
reason I bring that up to explain why
people vote against their own what we
consider to be their own interests which
is a central theme of what's the matter
with Kansas and a lot of other books is
because the Republicans figured out that
people will vote their emotions long
before the Democrats did in fact I think
many of the establishments and Democrats
still haven't figured it out Richard
Nixon was the bill clinton of our party
and said in this way that he is the
greatest political mind and the
republicans have had in the last in my
lifetime anyway
Bill Clinton hasn't raised political
mind the Democrats have had and we're
living under the party of Richard Nixon
in this way Richard Nixon was actually
would be a Democrat today
philosophically Richard Nixon figured
out that hate and anger motivates people
he he was the one who decided that the
Republicans designed the Southern
Strategy in 1968 they decided that he
would appeal to the right to race
baiting in the south in order to get the
Wallace voters become Republican which
he succeeded in doing so what the
Republicans have done for the last 40
years really is run out and talk about
minorities in the civil rights business
then gaze karl rove putting gay marriage
in the ballot in 16 states where it was
already illegal and now immigrants and
so they what they do is they push the
anger and the hate button and about
thirty five percent of republicans and
republican primaries will vote on those
kinds of issues so we sit here and
blather on i don't mean this is not
attack on you because i don't because
I've done it myself but we we Democrats
blather on about the the issues and the
structure and the capitalism stuff well
they're talking about stuff that just
pisses people off and that motivates and
go Latin and now why is this a good
thing it's a good thing because these
guys don't get pissed off about that
stuff I say this is a generation that
unlike us look we all fought the civil
rights movement all of us at the time
liberals right or did whatever we did
for the civil rights movement and fine
but we haven't grow up with anybody look
different than me which was a wide
experience these guys grow up with
people and go to school with people and
live with people every day of different
ethnicities different races different
religions different sexual orientations
and they all date each other this is a
different world that these guys are
growing up and so the hate pitch is not
going to work for this group this age
group and they are going to be freed by
that to do much more sensible things and
it's actually I've had I do have some
Republican friends even some
conservative Republican friends who are
pretty reasonable they're not many but
there are some and of course they'd
never want to be seen in public with me
but the fact is they know they have to
make the switch that the hate based wing
of the Republican Party is getting
smaller and smaller every year
and as the younger people arise this is
the barrier between the Republican Party
and young people in terms of their
fiscal views because they are more
conservative fiscally than the than the
left-wing the Democratic Party but they
are never going to get anybody this age
unless they stop talking about beating
up on Muslims gays immigrants and and
other minority groups and I find it so
this is about emotion it's it's not just
about the desire of the Koch brothers to
get richer and greedy or by manipulating
all this stuff it's about function
scaring people the world isn't going to
is going to be full of people who don't
look like you anymore and they're going
to be running everything and so
terrifying and they're going to marry
your daughters well guess what that's
exactly what's happening and hallelujah
it's going to cure the country well on
that optimistic note I want to ask one
last question before we open it up and
it actually follows very closely on what
on what you were just saying and you
mentioned Richard Nixon and as as as you
said if if he were governing today and
we were not at least ignoring his
rhetoric for a moment just what he did
once in office he looked like a
full-fledged Social Democrat biggest
expansion of Social Security in American
history creation of the Environmental
Protection Agency consumer protection
laws and income tax predict well and and
not to mention that he proposed a basic
minimum income which was failed because
liberals didn't think it was went far
enough but that's another story so if we
if we think about what's shifted it
clearly Nixon pioneered a new kind of
Republican strategy but another aspect
of our political economy more broadly
that Katrina's alluded to is that at the
time unions were much stronger there was
a different kind of business
establishment there's a famous wonderful
letter from Ike Eisenhower to his
brother in which he talks about how oh
yeah there's a few you know politicians
and and and and rich million in a
millionaire oilman who might want to
fight unions and roll back the New Deal
but they are small and number and they
are stupid and this was 1953 I think and
sort of summed up a kind of liberal
establishment that was built ultimately
on an organizational counterweight to
corporate power
in broad based class cross-class civic
organizations and in unions and so it
seems like an appropriate place to end
to kind of go from the framing and
messaging and emotional side of voters
to thinking more broadly about the
organizations that link them into
politics and I know that both you
governor didn't you Daniel have to think
I know you've been thinking about this
between it but I know that both you've
been working in organizations that are
doing this so I I'd love to to get your
reflections on how do you get rebuild a
kind of middle class democracy that's
built on a strong Civic Civic foundation
and Daniel maybe you could start us off
well I think part of that has to do with
putting in place and continuing to put
in place connections of sorry
protections for people and being able to
communicate what those meet and you
brought up Elizabeth Warren I think
she's a phenomenal example I was
watching an interview for recently where
she's talking about some of the
protections they're putting in place and
she says she's talking about Morgan is
and she says would you buy a toaster the
head a you know sixty percent chance of
blowing up no so then why is it okay to
give someone a mortgage to essentially
trick someone into getting a mortgage
that has a sixty percent chance of
essentially blowing up and she's really
connecting to people on those
protections that they want for
themselves there was a new york times
article a couple months back about the
obama administration's selling of its
economic policies a huge percentage of
americans think that the bank bailouts
occurred not during the bush
administration but during the obama
administration the vast majority of
americans who got tax cuts during the
Obama administration don't know that
they did and so we're putting all of the
left is trying to build these
protections into our system and they're
not talking about it well and I think
that that's going to be a huge part of
making sure we can build this agenda
going forward and you think that
organizations and sort of movements are
also crucial and sort of great at
letting people better understand what is
at stake in policy debates it I think
organizations are useful in that and I
think all organizations are also forward
and pushing new
ideas and you get thoughtful people
together working on these issues feeling
united and they're going to come up with
some ideas that they wouldn't have come
up with on their own I think that's what
some of these organizations you
mentioned snap and Roosevelt and some
organizations are doing that I think
will have a difference down the road I'm
curious governor Dean each of you can
speak to this question you know what
what where does you you have done an
enormous amount of organizing around a
partisan cause right around the
resurrection of the Democratic Party
what about the kind of cause of the
middle class more Bradley what do you
think their unions are one place to look
but whatever what are others well is to
be totally candid about unions some of
them are really very successful in a lot
of them aren't the ones that are
recruiting people & tank taking
progressive social views stands i would
mention the american federation of
teachers in SC I you as two of the
leaders are okay they're under siege but
they're doing okay but there are a lot
of the industrial unions that have been
mostly protecting their workers high
wage and not doing any new recruiting
and that's a big problem so you know
unions are institutions like everybody
else whether it's the church or any Yale
or pick any large institution if it
can't fix itself and it can't reinvent
itself then ultimately of course it
fails under the shackles of not of lack
of change and when times do change one
of the things I find extraordinary about
this general and so what I would say is
yeah institutions matter but the
incredibly refreshing thing about this
under 35 generation is that they become
less relevant because when you're
instead of beating your head against the
institution going through the painful
process of change that we've been doing
on a kind of a long-term basis in human
history this group now has a tool where
they don't have to bother with
government if they don't feel like it
they go to the internet they find a
hundred people that agree with them and
they go do something about it and they
don't never get to the board of alder
Board of Aldermen let alone the state
legislature of the Congress so movements
have their place but the nature of
movements have different the nature of
movements has to do with communications
when I got to the DNC we basically had
no
network of high-tech to speak of all
that we had a terrific new building
thanks to terry and all the things we
needed mechanically but none of the
computer stuff so we the network we
built was not about getting everybody to
give money in an efficient way it was
about essentially a decentralized
network with the message and the message
message was okay but it wasn't unified
because every little fiefdom in
Washington want to have their own way of
doing things and as long as you do that
you can't have a unified message what we
did do though was and thanks to Barack
Obama was a terrific candidate and had
Dave pluff who I think is the best
political operative that I've ever known
and ran the best campaign I've ever seen
we did have a sense that for this
generation the decentralization that
comes with using the net the kind of
freedom to morph ideas and not
necessarily test them and to put them
out in the marketplace is what is that
is a huge step forward a huge difference
and it's made possible by the by the
invention of the internet and the last
thing I'd say about this is enormous it
is I agree I feel terrible some days
about the corporate power and all these
things but look what's happened to the
media more than fifty percent of people
your age get their news from Jon Stewart
or the internet because the media it we
all agonize in our age group about the
you know Fox and all this kind of stuff
there are relevant for these guys they
just find their own news sources now
we'd better have a pretty good education
so you can tell the difference what's
not true which is about fifty percent of
it what is true which is the other fifty
percent and how you tell the difference
i'm not sure but everything is changing
and in this business of movements is
very important but movements themselves
the nature of institutionalized
movements is going to be so different
there was when i was here and we were
organizing for these guys because the
tools have changed so very very much as
i actually think your generations
thinking is sculpted as much by the
internet as you sculpt the internet I
respect governor Dean but you know your
campaign was extraordinary but it still
needed you it had the internet but it
needed you what I mean is I'm not
internet evangelist though I do think
the power of the Internet as we've seen
from Cairo Tunisia to Madison and beyond
is very very important but you're still
seeing a media a mainstream media and
I'm not even talking about Fox which a
majority for now people get their news
from that and that is truly the
downsized politics of excluded
alternatives with some exceptions on
MSNBC which is opening up a little bit
of a radar but no but it's still very
much within an establishment and the
kinds of sources voices you hear I think
you still need a kind of restructure
this is where I do think you need a new
kind of labor movement the obstacles to
building a vibrant labor movement as
it's currently defined are tough we need
new kind of open source unionism and
that's where the internet is also
valuable but you need people on the
ground I still think you need as the
Christian Right had people in the
churches you need people in the 21st
century equivalent of labor halls and in
the streets as well as on the internet
on the young people never forget you
know the social mobility in this country
and I don't mean to be Debbie the downer
has really broken down in many ways it
really has a long tied to the
unprecedented in equality the stagnant
wages the assault on the middle class
and I think young people are coming out
with more college debt maybe not from
the elite schools I think the
educational system in this country needs
modernization and a revamp student you
know so i think it's not fully clear to
me that you may not have a younger
generation which is going to face a
jobless recovery student debt and all
kinds of mobility issues but the media
is a real obstacle in this country i
agree more and more people get their
stuff on the internet but a lot of it
governor is still aggregated from the
top websites are still the main news
corporate sites and then you know it's
it's continuing not to give coverage for
example and that's what we try to do at
the nation to cover what is
underreported to cover those movements
in action those political leaders state
local initiatives sweet victories as I
call them that give people hope that
their action
can lead to a different kind of country
and an alternative to the world we live
in more just more fair and that will
require a leap of imagination which many
people are not willing to make until
they see that so it's it's it's a it's a
moment of complexity